salle de spectacle et cinéma vont ils
fermés ou bien s'adapter
les mesures gouvernementales annoncées
mercredi 14 octobre vont une nouvelle
fois impacté le monde culturel qui
commençait tout juste à reprendre
il entend se mobiliser pour maintenir
une offre est resté ouvert tout en
respectant le couvre-feu évidemment il
ya des spectacles qu'on va pas pouvoir
se présenter mais on va maintenir le
théâtre ouvert et présenter le maximum
de spectacles dans les contraintes qui
nous sont imposées aujourd'hui faire
moins de séances adapter les horaires
des spectacles pour respecter le
couvre-feu de 21h les salles auront 48
heures pour réagir
on est un peu pris de court au nom
d'allah prend par exemple pour un
concert qui a acquis a lieu samedi
c'est vrai qu'en terme de communication
va être un peu court pour dire aux gens
c'est pas à 20h30 c'est à 18h oui de
perdre on risque de perdre beaucoup
beaucoup de monde en route
je pense qu'on va décaler les sens
effectivement plus tôt c'est à dire on
va peut-être organiser les dernières
séances vers 18h30 19h de façon à ce
qu'à 21h les cinémas soit fermé une
discussion devrait avoir lieu demain
avec la ministre de la culture roselyne
bachelot une dérogation pourrait être
envisagée il est possible je dirais pas
probable que d'ici la fin de la journée
les théâtres puisse avoir une dérogation
pour terminer à 21h c'est à dire l'idée
c'est que les publics puis s'est
justifié avec leur billet dès leur
sortie du théâtre pour rentrer chez eux
un peu plus tard en juillet le ministère
de la culture a annoncé une baisse
moyenne du chiffre d'affaires de 25% en
2020 par rapport à 2019 soit un déficit
de près de 22 milliards d'euros